You've just found yourself the tales of Mr. Collector,
a limited edition story collection from Doctor Wondertainment.
*faint* Oh shit, oh shit oh shit oh shit oh shit.
*louder* Oh shit!
My name is Jeremy Adams, and I'm 22 and I'm being chased by a monster.
I don't know what's going on,
I don't know how this is possible, or what I'm supposed to do.
The thing won't stop.
I've been running for-
Oh.
God -  only fifteen minutes.
Feels like longer.
I'm exhausted, and it won't stop!
I didn't do anything wrong.
I just saw this guy on the subway,
It's night, we were the only people in the car.
He looked a bit odd, a bit gray and glassy eyed,
Which... was odd because from his hands
I would have guessed he was black or Indian or something.
We got off the same stop and I guess I wasn't looking where I was going
Because I bumped into him, and his head fell off.
I mean... that doesn't happen!
And then he got up and chased after me.
That-
That- can't happen.
How is it even following me anyhow?
It's not like it has eyes.
*irritated* Oh, another door locked.
No!
Can't someone have left their door unlocked tonight?
Please, I just need to get away from this thing-
And there it is! How.. did it... get behind me?
Oh shit... shit, shit-TRASHCAN!
I grab one and swing it straight into the thing's chest
and it stumbles backwards and collapses
and I'm off running before it can get back up.
Thank you, adrenaline.
How can this alley be a dead end?
It can't be, I need to escape!
It's not fair!
Walls, walls, damn it!
Too high and too slick and it's found me.
Anything around?
No.
I can't fight, but I try to punch it
and it's strong and this doesn't make any sense
and is that a blade?! And-
*brief sound of blade slashing*
Much, much better.
Could hardly even hear with that old one by the end.
This one's good.
Young, healthy,
should last me for weeks.
Colorblind, but you can't have everything.
And let's see…
Reasonably bright, too.
I just hope I didn't get too far off track getting this one.
Mr. Redd, I'm coming for you.
And I can't wait to find out what
wonderful thoughts I can think with that head of yours.